[Music]
Miley Cyrus and Liam Hemsworth are truly
in love there's no point denying us
we're you know super happy more than
anything is like he you know he is my my
best friend a source tells ET the couple
is more committed to each other than
ever and an upcoming wedding could be in
the stars cool
it's incredible after nine years of
on-and-off romance the source says their
timing is finally right one of their
biggest obstacles their families
the source explained quote while Miley's
parents have always adored Liam
Liam's parents were not sold on Miley
and her outrageous behavior Miley has
been very open about her drug and
alcohol use and that did it bode well
with his family's far more conservative
lifestyle but now that Miley has
seemingly changed her image and even
admitted she quit smoking weed she's won
over Liam's family
a dream come true when it comes to their
wedding the source says Miley and Liam
aren't rushing but the singer has come
up with some ideas for their special day
Miley a country girl at heart wants to
keep it simple and have a ranch wedding
and get this when it does happen it'll
be very under wraps quote Miley is being
very secretive so only their friends
will know and at the very last minute
this time they are doing everything
their own way
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]